les enfants de dieu suite du feuilleton
ou plutôt il faut dire la famille car
c'est le nouveau nom de cette communauté
qui a l'âme alimenter les faits divers
il ya quelques semaines les membres de
la communauté la famille donc ont été
lavés les principaux soupçons en tout
cas de sévices sur les enfants ces mêmes
enfants ont été rendus à leurs proches
21 adultes sont toujours tout de même
mise en examen en tout cas la communauté
s'est reformé et il faut le dire
elle s'est refermée car c'est le propre
de ce qu'il faut bien appeler ces sectes
elles vivent refermée sur elle même
comment enquête à nantes et à marseille
d'antoine cormery de patrice voler comme
une image d'épinal une famille heureuse
des enfants souriants
c'était l'heure des retrouvailles après
deux mois de séparation mais l'image a
son revers toujours dissimulé une vie
fermé très peu de contact avec le monde
extérieur et un discours simple ici le
paradis là bas hors les murs le mal le
péché l'enfer posters à l'appui toujours
les mêmes desseins manichéen la base
d'un conditionnement constaté au cours
de l' enquête en que disent les experts
sur cette affaire chacun a pu constater
qu'on avait affaire à des enfants qui
étaient robotisée qui était parfaitement
programmé qui avait été j'allais dire
programmé pour pouvoir répondre aux
services de police pour pouvoir répondre
un juge pour pouvoir parler à un avocat
pour pouvoir répondre aussi un
journaliste c'est d'ailleurs des gosses
qui sont préparés à la perfection
conditionné et parfois jusqu'à la
psychose à nantes mickaël est soigné
dans cet hôpital psychiatrique
certains de ses frères et soeurs pour
élire rejoindre leurs parents cette
semaine n'ont pas souhaité nous
rencontrer
ils sont toujours mises en examen pour
excitation de mineurs à la débauche ces
documents ne sont jamais distribué au
public la communauté y puise ses règles
de vie
ces modes de raisonnement contre
l'amérique contre israël par exemple la
mauvaise société d'un point de vue
sexuel aussi les indications sont très
précises avec souvent dans les dessins
la mise en scène de jeunes adolescents
l'homme à tête de lion n'est jamais bien
loin
c'est moïse david le gourou un enfant
lorsqu'il a subi un conditionnement de
dison d'une dizaine d'années lorsque cet
enfant il a dix ans 12 ans présent
toutes ces personnalités a été structuré
selon le modèle sectaire et il n'y a
absolument aucune possibilité de choix
aux possibilités de de réflexion par
rapport à la normalité
l'enquêté sociale et à partir de ce
moment là il n'a pratiquement aucune
chance d'intégration pour l'avenir l'
enquête de la justice ne fait que
commencer et peut-être répondra-t-elle à
une question que se passait-il vraiment
dans chaque famille pour chaque enfant